local authentic fresh that is via brazil
steakhouse who is sponsoring this next
segment and they're hosting one big and
meaty game party here to tell us more is
lena and christy welcome to the show
hello thank you for having us it's great
to have you guys here so tell me what's
happening on sunday during the big game
so sunday we are having a
super bowl event party
so our whole restaurant will have
surround sign of the big game we have
150 inch screens all of our restaurants
and our bar and we're going to use our
full capacity to host a lot of people
and all of our returning customers that
come and dine with us almost every day
and every
event as well
so on that day we'll also be having a
full dinner which is going to be a
regular dinner it's 54.99 per adult and
that's a lot of meat what's the one
there's 19 or 17 meats
all you can eat of steak chicken pork
seafood our most famous one is the pecan
this right here is iconic right here yes
that is the one you want to definitely
want to go for now when i think big game
i think of food i think of meat i think
all the stuff you guys got i also think
of drinks we're to make one here today
what are we going to make i am going to
teach you how to make a traditional
brazilian caiparina today so our open
bar will include other things as well
but this is a traditional brazilian
cocktail right walk me through it so
you're going to start with a fresh lime
fresh lime okay always fresh limes very
simple drink so you're going to take
nice juicy fresh lime you're going to
cut off just the little knobs on both
ends all right okay maybe with a knife
this could be trouble just slide this
thing off here you just want to cut just
a little bit off the end you guys
mentioned open bar as well that's an
option on sunday yes it's fifty dollars
per person so then you're going to cut
it in half long ways here long ways so
our open bar will include vodka tequila
rum whiskey the sangria's and then also
this drink we're making right here
that's perfect so you're going to take
your lime that you just cut and you're
going to cut it again long ways in half
okay i got about 45 seconds here all
right and then you're going to cut it
into thirds okay
we'll get an educational how to cut a
line mirror tell you that much this is
good you want to squeeze it kind of keep
it all together here the best you can
drop it right into your glass okay
all right then you want one level
spoonful of sugar oh this is a very
sweet drink brazilian drinks are very
sweet very refreshing very delicious
you're gonna take your muddler here oh i
think i'm doing it wrong it's okay
that's why you we got about 30 seconds
i'll let you take over and show everyone
watching show america how to make this
drink you're going to take your muddler
here you're going to muddle it right in
the glass
you just want a nice layer of lime juice
to cover the sugar
then you are going to take a scoop of
ice all right
you are going to take your cachaca you
want 1.5 ounces of cachaca load it up i
feel like this is the perfect game too
with the big game being in la on sunday
the weather is gonna be perfect this is
a nice refreshing cocktail bathroom
again sweet refreshing drink to just sit
down this is the trick i admire you with
the bartender so much the way you shake
this thing up i was afraid to see them
flying out but you're not gonna shake it
just right you want everything to be
mixed up very well
then you just pop it out and pour i love
it add some straws
and you're good to go we're good to go
to celebrate the big game that's perfect
thank you so much and thank you to via
brazil steakhouse for sponsoring this
segment give them a call at
702-804-1400 or visit via
brazilsteakhouse.com
we'll be right back cheers